Come on:
Hasn't everyone here dreamt of flying?
So why haven't humans flown yet?
I've been obsessed with
learning to fly my whole life.
I grew up a feral, adopted child
on the northern shore of Lake Ontario,
following my bricklayer/fisherman
father around.
I was always fascinated
by things that moved,
catching small animals,
holding them in my hands,
feeling the magic of their movement;
playing with fire,
thrilled and terrified at
its unrelenting force,
accidentally burning
my father's barn down --
just once.
(Laughter)
That was my first brush with real danger,
the fire and my father.
When I was about eight or nine years old,
I caught a fly in a mason jar.
Studying that fly, I thought, "Wow,
it's changing directions
in midair with acute angles,
and it's going so fast, it's a blur.
Why can't we do that? Can we?"
Everywhere I looked,
there were things moving.
And these things moved
with their very own causal rhythms,
their very own mechanistic anatomies.
It was clear to me -- and to Newton --
that things move based
on their component parts:
worms squirmed, birds flew,
kangaroos hopped.
And a human's first bout with flying
was falling accidentally, tripping,
or slipping on that fabled banana peel.
Once your ground is dragged
out from under you,
a world of wonder comes rushing in.
I had found my territory.
I was seized with a compulsion,
a primordial urge to learn how to fly,
like a human.
For the next 10 years,
I did my experiments alone,
on my own body.
I drove my Honda 350
across the United States
in an "Easy Rider" kind of way.
I got my degree in modern dance.
I mimicked that fly in the box.
I dove horizontally through glass;
on the way, I punched a hole in it.
I was trying to figure out
something about flight.
When I was 27 years old,
I found myself in a rat-infested
New York City loft,
getting ready to hurl myself off a ladder.
I climbed higher, higher, higher,
and I jumped.
Wham-o! I landed.
That hurt.
(Laughter)
And it occurred to me that people
didn't really enjoy getting hurt,
and that maybe the reason
that we weren't flying yet
is that we were still attached
to that false idea
that we would fly the way birds do,
or butterflies.
Maybe we needed to assumption-bust,
to ask a different kind of question --
about duration, for instance.
Humans in the air? A few seconds.
Birds and butterflies?
Minutes, maybe hours.
And what about fear?
I think fear is complex and personal.
I really think it has to do with curiosity
and not taking yourself so seriously.
We might need to get a little hurt,
just not too hurt.
And pain: redefine it.
Rather than "pain," say, "another
rather interesting, foreign sensation."
Something like that.
I realized then that to learn to fly,
we were going to have to learn to land.
My hero, Evel Knievel --
one of them -- said,
"Anyone can jump a motorcycle.
The trouble begins
when you try to land it."
(Laughter)
Landing hurts.
I was curious, though.
I thought, "Well, why don't we invent
an impact technique?
Why don't we just expand
our base of support?"
I had seen pieces of plywood fall,
and they didn't flinch on the way down.
So I made my body into a perfect line
and tilted back.
Whaft!
It was a totally different
sound than "wham-o."
And I rushed out onto
the streets of New York City
and went up to complete strangers,
and I said -- well, I thought --
"I did a backfall today. Did you?"
In 1985, we started to tour
all over the world a little bit,
and I started my company,
called STREB EXTREME ACTION.
In 2003, we were invited
to go to Kitty Hawk
to celebrate the 100th anniversary
of flight with the Wright Brothers.
We had gotten very good at landing;
now we needed to get up into the air.
And like them, we wanted
to stay there longer.
I came across this quote by Wilbur:
"If you are looking for perfect safety,
you will do well to sit on a fence
and watch the birds;
but if you really wish to learn,
you must mount a machine
and become acquainted
with its tricks by actual trial."
Ah, machines.
It incited the hardware
junkie inside of me.
And if we did want to go or travel
to unhabitual places in space --
to that banana peel spot that confuses us;
to that place outside
our vertical comfort zone,
where we encounter unexpected turbulence
and get accelerated oddly,
where the ground changes
and moves out from under us --
like the composer
who is trying to hit a note
higher than the human voice can sing,
he invents a piccolo or a flute,
I set about the invention
of my prototypic machines.
And if we wanted to go
higher, faster, sooner, harder,
it was necessary that we create
our very own spaceships.
And we did.
And we did travel to unknown,
invisible, dangerous territories,
and it changed us.
If any of you want
to try this, let me know.
(Laughter)
In 2012, we brought all
of our best machines to London
and put them in their most iconic places.
We got on the London Eye.
It was 443 feet above the earth.
And as we reached the zenith,
we unlocked our brake and fell --
200 feet on the radius,
on the spoke that we were attached to.
We reached as far up as heaven that day,
I'm pretty sure of it.
And then I and two of my dancers
walked down the outside
of London's City Hall.
As I stood up there,
300 feet above the ground,
and looked down,
I saw 2,000 eyes staring up at me,
and they saw what they usually do --
the sky, a bird, a plane -- and then us.
And we were just a tiny speck up there.
And I realized that action
is for everybody.
Now we have our very own
mason jar in Williamsburg, Brooklyn.
It's called SLAM: STREB Lab
for Action Mechanics.
It was a former mustard seed factory.
And I designed it after
the use of a petri dish,
and in that petri dish,
I put Kid Action, STREB EXTREME ACTION
and circus arts,
and we all learned to fly, fall and land
and invent extreme action together.
And you know what we found?
In comes everyone --
every size, shape, age, capacity,
every nationality, every race,
every class, all genders,
the timid and the bold,
the outcast and the cool,
the risk avoiders and the risk obsessives.
And these buildings exist
all over the world,
and every one of them can be
a flying training center.
And you know, as it turns out,
people don't want
to just dream about flying,
nor do they want to watch us fly.
They want to do it, too, and they can.
And with a little training,
they learn to relish
the hit and the impact,
and, I guess even more,
getting up afterwards.
I've found that the effect of flying
causes smiles to get more common,
self-esteem to blossom,
and people get just a little bit braver.
And people do learn to fly,
as only humans can.
So can you.
Come fly with us.
(Applause)
(Music)
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
(Applause)